we go about this the right way we'll
have a place to call home in no time
whenever i built up settlements back
west
i always made sure to bring the right
people together to do the job
because it's specialists it'll take all
of this to the next level without them
we can't move forward right now we're
still short on specialists they're out
there cap bring them back to prosperity
and i'll take care of the rest
our intel company was founded by a kid
named bean
he's a sweetheart but he needs so much
looking after
last i heard some critical document has
been stolen from it
if you found it for him he'd probably
find a way to repay you
oh linda james
those bucks are bleeding me dry i could
barely feed myself before they showed up
oh um
hello
them
those losers in prosperity must have
done it so you know what prosperity's
gonna pay
oh
i need a runner my knees are just no
good oh thank goodness you're so nice
i'm bean creator of wikipedia you know
your one-stop shop for maps and intel
wikipedia just the tips
but here's the rub
wikipedia is in danger my key assets are
all gone intel maps you name it now my
business plan is missing too
but but i i know who gave me the shaft
my employee richard he's got a real bad
gambling habit always playing crazy
eights with those highway men and losing
his pants he must have hidden the plants
somewhere for safekeeping he'll they
just take it from him they're not very
nice or respectful his usual gambling
place isn't far from here if you spook
him he'll run and lead you right to his
hidey hole i'm sure of it
i'd go but i've got bad knees
and lungs
and eyes
anyway please get my business plan back
if you reach around my back now i'll
reach around yours later that's a
wikipedia promise
uh
yep
must be the ozone space
[__] is happening
help me oh god please help
go pick on someone with clothes on
[Music]
i need help please someone help
please don't hurt me i'm uh obviously
unarmed
i have no concealed weapon i swear
oh
um
look okay yes i lost my clothes in a
game of cards hahaha i have a problem
all right
i didn't mean for things to get this bad
i was one of bean scouts and i thought
that since the highwaymen travel so much
they'd be a good source of information
they said they'd play me for it and
before i knew it i'd gambled away all of
bean's assets the only things i had left
to offer were the clothes off my back
and bean's business plan the plan's in
my secret stash in a little bunker just
over the hill there i promise i'll never
gamble again
oh cruz please help me
what
somebody make this duck
[Music]
[Applause]
here
[Music]
hello oh gosh is that how my voice
sounds
over
wait no not not over i wanted to tell
you i had to relocate but by my estimate
i'm closer to where you ought to be head
um south i think you'll find me i know
you will
oh
you ever hear of our local crackpot
larry parker
he's long gone but i bet he left behind
some good things that nobody's found yet
hmm
it
this is gonna have a happy ending
just like my favorite story books
i'd plop for joy but my daddy always
said that was for clowns and babies and
i'm neither
remember i mentioned the reach around
your back well i'm gonna set up
wikipedia hq and prosperity starting now
i got scouts collecting hot tips and
i'll get maps again and well you'll see
with my business plan wikipedia will go
global just like daddy always talked
about how it was before
everyone will help us and give us
donations it'll be great
i'll see you at prosperity soon right
right i can't wait well i have a nice
time until then
you